Rats are crawling all over the "House of the
Dragon," but are they just a metaphor, or something more?
And where have we seen that mysterious red
flower before?
For several weeks in a row, various rodents
have scurried in and out of frame on "House
of the Dragon."
In Episode 6, Viserys spots a mouse on a mantle
as he's alone in his bedchamber, as viewers
hear Larys tell Queen Alicent about the weakness
of children.
But the most overt inclusion of a rat is the
one that drinks the recently deceased Ser
Joffrey Lonmouth's blood as Rhaenyra and Laenor
exchange their vows in Episode 5.
Many readers of "Fire & Blood" feel like the
rats are an indicator of an upcoming plotline
that, if the show follows the book, would
be a huge spoiler, so we'll say no more about that here.
But King's Landing's prominent vermin problem
might have another explanation.
Though there's no textual evidence for this
theory in George R.R.
Martin's writing, Reddit moderator and YouTuber
Joe Magician has laid out the possibility
that a character on "House of the Dragon"
could be a skinchanger like Bran Stark.
If so, the rats could be being used to spy
and gather information.
Ten years on, it seems like every move mortal
enemies Princess Rhaenyra and Queen Alicent
make is a power play.
Episode 6 opens with Rhaenyra's delivery of
her third child.
Just about the moment the midwife places the
baby in the princess' arms, a messenger arrives
to take the newborn to the queen's chambers.
Rhaenyra will not have her son separated from
her so quickly.
Before she's even passed the placenta, she
dresses to make the long walk through the Red Keep.
Her husband, Laenor Velaryon, accompanies
her and holds her upright as she has to stop
each time she has an afterbirth contraction.
During one of these moments on the stairs,
Lord Caswell and his lady wife approach Rhaenyra
and Laenor enthusiastically.
"If I may be of any service?"
"The day may yet come, my lord."
This seems like a subtle bit of foreshadowing
on the show's part, as prominent families
begin to take sides.
House Caswell appears to be staunchly loyal
to Rhaenyra as tension and uncertainty about
the succession mounts, and that loyalty will
likely soon be tested in dramatic fashion.
After Rhaenyra wills herself to the queen's
private quarters, she presents the newborn
prince to Alicent, who's basically become
her evil stepmother, and her father King Viserys,
who's shockingly still alive, though just
barely.
Viserys is genuinely happy to meet the child
and remarks that he thinks the boy has his
father's nose.
When the queen asks what they'll call him,
Rhaenyra begins to say they haven't decided,
but then Laenor bursts out the name "Joffrey"
which probably made "Game of Thrones" fans perk up.
But the name is a reference to another murdered
Joffrey from nearly two centuries prior, and
Alicent can't hide her feelings about it.
"That's an unusual name for a Velaryon."
With this polite-enough sounding comment,
Alicent is actually making two accusations.
Though we only met him briefly, Joffrey was
the first name of Laenor's lover — Ser Joffrey
Lonmouth, the Knight of Kisses — who was
brutally murdered by Ser Criston Cole at the
welcome feast in Episode 5.
Laenor and Joffrey's relationship was an open
secret, at least at Driftmark and probably
even at King's Landing.
Still, for the queen to underscore the fact
that the future king consort wants to name
his purported son after his murdered boyfriend
is remarkably bold.
Alicent is also implying that she knows this
child, like the previous two, isn't really
Laenor's, since she's well aware of his sexual
preferences.
"Do keep trying, Ser Laenor.
Sooner or later, you may get one who looks
like you."
King Viserys' small council has changed considerably
over the years.
Corlys Velaryon has been replaced by Tyland
Lannister as Master of Ships.
When Otto Hightower was dismissed as Hand
of the King, Lyonel Strong was chosen to fulfill
that most important role.
Only Lyman Beesbury remains in his original
position of Master of Coin.
But two of the most noticeable changes to
the king's council are the addition of his
daughter, Princess Rhaenyra, and his wife,
Queen Alicent.
Rhaenyra was promoted from cupbearer to council
member after being named heir and Princess
of Dragonstone.
A decade later, a much more politically active
Alicent also has a seat at the table.
Production designers conceived of small spheres
to signify a character's presence at the small
council table, each in colors that represent
the great houses to which the council members belong.
Queen Alicent sits behind a green ball that's
reminiscent of Hightower's colors and her
infamous gown, while Rhaenyra rolls her fingers
across a black one for House Targaryen.
These totems demonstrate that both have accumulated
immense power in the last decade, regardless
of their opposition to each other.
Earlier in the season, it was frowned upon
for the princess to speak at all when she's
with the lords behind the closed doors of
the small council room.
Now, she and Alicent are practically running
the show, though they seem to disagree about everything.
We met Lyonel Strong's sons, Harwin and Larys,
during the hunt in Episode 3.
Larys has since ingratiated himself to Queen
Alicent by becoming her unofficial Master
of Whisperers while Harwin has entangled himself
in some deadly serious palace drama by fathering
Rhaenyra's three children.
Savvy viewers will have noticed that Harwin
was quite taken with Rhaenyra after she killed
the boar, and when she donned boys' clothing
on the Streets of Silk.
He's also the one who carries her to safety
after the melee at the welcome feast.
Larys doesn't seem to have a very high opinion
of his father, the Hand, or his brother.
When Queen Alicent complains that King Viserys
wouldn't accept Lyonel's resignation after
Harwin attacks Ser Criston in the training
yard, Larys graduates from whispers to actions.
Lyonel takes Harwin to the family seat of
Harrenhal, which is said to be cursed, to
avoid persistent rumors of the princes' parentage.
Meanwhile, Larys frees some of King's Landing's
most dangerous prisoners, so long as they're
okay with him cutting off their tongues so
they can't spill the beans.
He sends his assassins to Harrenhal to murder
his father and brother via arson, which he
tells a horrified Alicent that she'll thank
him for later, as he holds the foreign flower
to which he previously compared her.
"An outsider, among the natives."
"Lord Larys."
In "Fire & Blood," Larys isn't just Master
of Whisperers; he's Lord Confessor.
That title is a euphemism for torturer-in-chief,
so it's no surprise to book readers that he's
so eager to break out the tools of his trade.